[Musique]
alors je sais pas vous mais je trouve
qu'on a entendu plein de belles
histoires cet après midi plein de super
idée mais en toute humilité je pense que
moi j'ai la meilleure nouvelle du jour à
vous annoncer
si si je vous jure c'est une excellente
nouvelle
vous après c'est la merde
si je vous jure c'est la mer non c'est
la mouise
c'est la crise et moi la crise moi
j'adore ça ça me fascine pas vous non
bof moi si j'adore la crise c'est parce
que tout du coup le chambouler son
dessus dessous
tout est à revoir et du coup ça devient
un formidable terrain de jeu d'invention
d'innovation et exploration du coup
derrière j'en ai même fait une
spécialité
je suis devenu une sorte de voyageurs
d'explorateurs de la crise alors mon
premier voyage en crise commence en 1987
j'ai 11 ans et je pars à berlin plus tôt
à berlin ouest parce qu'à l'époque il
est encore le mur et le petit garçon que
je suis comprend que l'humanité est
capable de couper un peu coupé un peuple
en deux je repars de ce voyage avec une
question lancinante pourquoi pourquoi
j'ai 11 ans c'est quoi ce truc des
grands je comprends pas en tout cas le
voyage ont un impact fondateur sur ma
vie et sur la suite de mes études et de
ma carrière
du coup dès mon premier boulot je pars
dans mon deuxième voyage en crise
et pas n'importe lequel 11 septembre
2001 pas besoin de vous rappeler le
niveau de crise qui avait un peu dans le
monde
je tourne en rond dans ma chambre
d'étudiant le petit garçon berlin me dis
que je dois agir
ma destination kaboul afghanistan
quand je me pose à kaboul je ne sais pas
encore mais je vais passer dix ans et là
sous mes yeux
vingt ans de guerre vingt ans de
souffrance 20 ans de deuil
je découvre l'absence de tout l'eau la
santé l'électricité l'éducation rien
mais à côté de ça comme vous peut voir
là ce formidable courage des afghans
leur incommensurable capacité à sourire
à rire à voir le bon côté des choses
même dans les situations inimaginables
pour nous y est
j'ai sous les yeux une évidence que
c'est dans la crise connaît l'espoir que
c'est dans la crise que naît la
résilience la volonté la créativité
finalement que c'est dans la merde que
naît la démerde
alors pour mon prochain voyage en crise
prenons de la hauteur
cette fois ci je pars dans l'espace dans
un voyage un peu virtuel alors tout
helix qui se respecte dans le monde
entier se doit d'avoir une slide avec la
terre vue de l'espace
la voilà elle est pour moi la case écho
chez nous pouvons continuer ce
magnifique tadic la rochelle en tout cas
voilà je pars virtuellement dans
l'espace et je pars observer le monde ou
plutôt un monde en particulier le monde
de l'éducation
j'ai là j'ai la chance aujourd'hui que
mon job consiste à de houston à delhi de
shanghai à lagos a observé essaie de
comprendre tout ce qui se fait tout ce
qui se dit tout ce qui se passe dans
l'éducation dans le monde entier
et devinez la très bonne nouvelle en
tout cas pour moi que j'entends aux
quatre coins du monde
l'éducation c'est quoi l'éducation c'est
quoi c'est la crise et ça forcément je
quiche comme question alors quelle crise
alors il ya beaucoup d'explications qui
sont donnés il y en a beaucoup qui sont
spécifiques à un contexte en tout cas
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de retenir quatre
explications à cette crise la première
c'est la crise du modèle
oui c'est vrai les codes de la
révolution industrielle a permis de
sortir des millions voire des milliards
de personnes de l'ignorance et de la
pauvreté
mais aujourd'hui comme on l'a bien
compris aujourd'hui le monde change et
malheureusement on ne peut plus penser
l'école que comme une usine qui année
après année emmène les élèves comme sur
une chaîne de production
on ne peut plus penser les matières en
silo isolées les unes des autres avec
bien par là l'histoire ici la physique
l'anglais les grecs latins peu importe
non plus possible deuxième crise crise
du lien entre éducation et emploi dont
le monde aujourd'hui il y a plusieurs
dizaines de millions de jeunes diplômés
qui sont sans emploi
l'ironie c'est qu'il ya des milliers
d'employeurs dans le monde entier qui
disent qu'ils n'arrivent pas à trouver
des jeunes diplômés avec les compétences
qu'ils cherchent
quelles sont ses compétences zoé on a un
peu parlé créativité communication
collaboration empathie pour ses
critiques
on nous dit aussi qu effectivement les
robots et l'intelligence artificielle
arrive et qui vont détruire des millions
des dizaines de millions d'emplois dans
le monde entier dans les 20 ans qui
viennent on nous explique que 60% des
métiers de demain n'existe pas
aujourd'hui alors créativité robot
métier qui n'existe pas l'école
d'aujourd'hui est-elle prête à relever
ce défi
troisième crise crise du monopole de la
connaissance
jadis l'école l'université étaient les
endroits on pouvait avoir accès à toute
la masse de savoirs et de connaissances
dans le monde et apprendre à connaître
le monde aujourd'hui avec les nouvelles
technologies
plus besoin on peut télécharger
directement nos connaissances dans nos
cerveaux parce que tout est à portée de
clic certains vont même jusqu'à dire
qu'on pourrait se passer des cols et
d'enseignants finalement c'est simple
personnellement je le crois pas je pense
que éducation et technologies vont
augmenter se compléter mutuellement en
tout cas ce soi-disant monopole de
l'école lui a bel et bien exploser
quatrième crise est peut-être pour moi
la plus grave crise de la motivation et
j'étais en chine il ya quelques semaines
et un directeur d'école me disait
les élèves ici sont physiquement
présents en classe mais émotionnellement
psychologiquement absent alors vous me
direz ouais rien de nouveau sous le
soleil
moi aussi j'ai pu j'ai passé les cours
au fond de la classe près du radiateur à
regarder par la fenêtre parce que je
m'ennuyais et ça c'est de l'ennui
aujourd'hui on a un problème de
motivation intrinsèque des élèves
voici en substance ce que j'entends à
peu près des quatre coins du monde de sa
part de la part de ces jeunes
alors je passe ma journée dans un
endroit pas très stimulant j apprends
des choses qu'on finalement peu de lien
avec ce qui se passe à l'extérieur je
continue à apprendre des trucs parker
que je peux accéder
excepté accéder par google et wikipédia
je suis pris dans une spirale du stress
des notes et de mots prêts étudiants
hélas là vous êtes en train de me dire
que même si je fais tous ses efforts
c'est même pas sûr que je puisse avoir
un bon boulot pour un boulot tout court
alors qu'est ce que je fous là à quoi ça
sert en fait ce qui est sûr c'est que
ces jeunes eux ils sont en crise et six
en crise nous sommes en crise avec messi
crise comme je faisais plutôt égal
opportunités ces crises de l'éducation
égale opportunité de repenser
l'éducation de penser une école de
l'avenir qui arriverait à rallumer
l'enthousiasmé et l'adhésion des élèves
alors vous allez me dire que je suis
naïf et idéaliste et vous savez quoi
depuis mon poste d'observation d'un
espace je vois qu'il y a dix qui sont
nombreux à essayer de donner vie à cette
école de demain et ce même dans les
endroits les plus pourris possible du
monde laissez moi vous donner un exemple
de quatre projets qui pour moi incarne
savent parfaitement et que j'adore en
haut à droite
c'est dans des vallées rural de pronoms
be à côté ici c'est des camps de
réfugiés syriens
lassé des plaines inondables du
bangladesh et enfin mais aussi les
quartiers défavorisés de détroit et de
chicago ces quatre projets se
ressemblent c'est
autre projet les élèves travaillent en
groupe ils travaillent en équipes ils
travaillent en ce qu'on appelle mode
projet c'est à dire que sur un mois sur
un semestre peut-être sur une année
entière
ils vont se mobiliser autour un problème
auquel ils vont chercher une solution
ce problème est un problème concret de
leur quartier de leur environnement
proche du cou qui les motive qui les
stimulent comme la gestion de l'eau la
gestion des ordures problèmes de
transport les enseignants eux se
fédèrent autour du projet des élèves
c'est à dire que chaque enseignant va
mener sa matière dans ce projet des
élèves
il va donc y avoir des apprentissages en
physique en histoire en maths en anglais
etc et j'en passe ces quatre projets
dans ces quatre projets il y à la
technologie mais quand il y en a c'est
pour libérer du temps pour que
l'enseignant fasse ce qu'il fait le
mieux c'est à dire véritablement passer
du temps avec ses élèves elle est
coachée à être leur mentor à être auprès
d'eux autre point commun dans ces quatre
projets très peu note très peu
d'exemples dans certains et n'a pas du
tout par contre une insistance
particulière à mesurer le progrès des
élèves pris individuellement et dans le
temps et vous savez quoi
et ça marche ces élèves apprennent à
apprendre
ils apprennent à reconnecter avec leur
motivation naturelle
ils sont prêts à avancer ils sont prêts
à changer métiers sont prêts à inventer
leur propre métier
finalement ils ont la confiance
nécessaire pour affronter la permanence
d'un monde qui bouge
alors moi ça je kiffe tout ça génial
du coup quand je rentre ici quand je
rentre en france et que j'essaie de
partager mon engouement
j'entends un peu trop souvent en tout
cas à mon goût la phrase suivante
non c'est super c'est bien la colombie
la sympa hein
le bangladesh c'est hyper qt comme
projet mais tu sais nous la france c'est
tellement particulier on est différent
tous les autres comprend charlemagne
jules ferry la génération
du bagne mahmoud et ceara que c'est cool
mais on n'a pas grand chose à apprendre
de tout ça et puis tu comprends ça ben
c'est le système le système
sauf que finalement le système le
système c'est vous c'est nous le système
c'est moi je suis le système
je suis père de deux enfants deux petits
garçons qui sont à l'école publique de
temps en temps je donne des cours à
l'université et surtout et peut-être
pire je suis un soi disant expert en
éducation
le père que je suis tous les jours
continuent à s'interroger est ce que
pour mes deux petits garçons je dois
continuer à rêver à ce qu'ils soient
formés à une spécialité une carrière
harare de nairas trice ou est-ce que
j'accepte que le monde change que le
monde bouge que mes deux petits garçons
là ils vont faire 14 15 20 métiers
différents dans leur ville que de toute
façon ces métiers il existe même pas
encore donc je peux pas attendre de
l'école qu elle les prépare à ça et si
ma réponse est oui il faut ce qui me
pose une deuxième question est ce que je
suis prêt mois a accepté que le modèle
qui m'a fort mais qui m'a protégé qui
m'a amené là où je suis aujourd'hui
puisse peut-être ne pas fonctionner en
l'état pour mes deux petits garçons en
tant qu'enseignant en tant qu'expert
vous l'avez vu de mon tour du monde moi
j'y crois et je pense qu'on peut passer
d'une école de la compétition à une
école de la collaboration à une école
qui ferait ce qu'elle sait faire de
mieux c'est à dire élevé véritablement
l'élève est d'ailleurs la bonne nouvelle
est là pour le coup je suis très sérieux
c'est que le changement est en cours en
france
je connais des dizaines des centaines
d'enseignants de classes d'écoles qui
jusqu'à récemment plutôt discrètement
mais de plus en plus ouvertement essaie
de donner vie à cette école de la
collaboration
alors oui le monde accélère
oui le changement risque d'être
permanent et donc oui c'est la crise
mais revenons à l'étymologie véritable
du mot crise krisis en grec qui veut
dire décidé faire un choix
alors attention si choix il ya pour moi
aucunement il naît entre ce que
j'entends aussi est trop souvent entre
le il faut surtout ne rien faire il faut
rien changer et ou à l'inversé à l'autre
extrême
il faut tout bazarder vous repartir à
zéro non pour moi le vrai choix
c'est le choix entre la peur ou
l'enthousiasmé face à l'impermanence des
choses pour nous aider à trancher les
émois terminait avec une petite histoire
un jour un fabricant de chaussures de
sport décide d'envoyer deux consultants
sur un continent pour voir s'il pourrait
y avoir un marché pour cette marque le
premier consultant revient effaré tout
le monde marche pieds nus il n'y aura
jamais aucun marché il faut surtout ne
pas y aller le deuxième consultant
revient hyper enthousiaste tout le monde
marche pieds nus c'est génial ya un
marché énorme une fouille aller qu'en
pensez vous
finalement ces deux analyses ces deux
expériences sont vrais et possible en
même temps on voit la différence où est
la vérité
et bien finalement en tout cas pour moi
c'est la même chose par rapport au monde
éducation nous avons le choix entre la
peur
et l'enthousiasmé c'est ce choix que
nous ferons qui déterminera l'école de
demain
merci
[Applaudissements]